his Twitter feed is a must it is
delightful and it's funny it's hilarious
on occasion it is a little bit of
heartbreaking because it's about life
and the e60 piece on this guy was just
dynamite and pleased and happy to be
able to call him a friend
he is Rex Chapman here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Rex hey buddy how you
doing hanging in there we are how about
you everyone you know happy healthy safe
can you yeah you know I mean few people
not knocked up beating up with this
stuff that I do know of and fortunately
so far they they're doing okay but scary
really scary no doubt about it no doubt
about it
did you ever think you'd become like a
social media star Rex that people look
to for for a moment of sanity do you
ever think you'd have that in you
absolutely not I'm not naturally a happy
just a happy-go-lucky guy I'm faking my
way through a lot of this and these are
scary times man so no I absolutely
didn't think I didn't think I could have
any or should have any kind of influence
on anyone but you do I mean how do you
choose what you post you know probably
just being a Twitter addict sitting
there scrolling the timeline coming
across things that I find and reach out
to somebody see if they'll you know mind
if I tweet it see if I can find a video
of that or you know and I've got some
pretty good friends out there now a
couple one in the Netherlands another in
London that we just kind of like the
same stuff and they'll send me videos
and I'll retweet some of their videos so
it's all really you know I think it is
what social media is so it's supposed to
be about instead of all the snarky
nonsense but I'm that guy too
I I can get that way and so you know I
guess it's just better to to be positive
right I know exactly and it's what
people are looking for it did all start
with the old block charge the blocker
blocker charged what was the first
blocker charge you posted Rex which one
was that
I really think yeah I really think I
don't know I know I came on with you
well first I came on with you rich yeah
a few years ago before all of this yeah
we were one of the first people that had
me on right after I gotten in trouble I
would probably wasn't out of rehab even
a year and I came over to your studio
there and what is it
Culver City yep and well we're in El
Segundo is in California and color
cities in front of it yep yeah and so
you know all of this stuff you guys
people have been great to me and it's
all been you know a huge part of me
trying to trying to rebound from you
know 15 16 years of addiction no way no
car you kidding me I mean come on now
Rex Chapman here on the Rich Eisen show
you know we've had Ryan Leaf on here Rex
and and he's been very very open about
his battles and what it means what would
you tell people who are listening right
now certainly there's a lot of alone
people right now that's one of the more
hard things about this virus is how it's
creating more and more loneliness for
right reasons we are all loving one
another by choosing to stay away from
one another right now at least that's
one way to look at it yeah what would
you say to people like that
Rex well I really and I'm glad you
brought this up because I was just you
know I swim normally and I you know you
can't swim can't go anywhere you can't
do anything pools are closed you know so
I'm just struggling with my own personal
you know mental health right now like
everyone else is this is a load this is
a load and I was walking today and I
just I remember I started thinking about
you know being all those all those years
all those days on opioids and pills and
the hardest thing once you're coming out
of that is when something goes bad in
your life you know a lot of people that
are that have these problems have legal
problems they have family problems work
problems and so once you've kind of
gotten clean dealing with the adversity
without reaching into your pocket for
pills
is one of the hardest things you'll do
so just
imagine right now everyone at home
lonely and the other thing about pills
there there you you know they're silent
there they don't smell they they don't
smell like weed they don't smell like
alcohol you can sort of blend in until
your life just falls apart so I would
tell people at home right now thread
very carefully thread very carefully
with all opioids don't take anything as
much as as we have over the years don't
take anything unless it's not prescribed
for you don't do that kids at home you
see these pill bottles in the cabinets
don't do it I'm just telling you I
wasn't a party guy I wasn't a drink or a
smoker none of that everybody will tell
you that all of my teammates and to be
one year out of the NBA after never
being in trouble my entire life being in
rehab and and from forevermore being you
know labeled a drug addict it's not
something that I had planned on and it
can happen to you whether you go out and
seek that sort of behavior wanting to
have fun and partying or whether you got
hurt and you know somebody puts you on
painkillers
it doesn't matter how you get there you
then got to get out of it and that's all
to say Rex Chapman here on the Rich
Eisen show and again I guess the the the
combination of loneliness boredom not
knowing how long this may last is a
depression rich right health you know
plays a big role in all of it because we
all process stuff very differently and
we're all wired very differently I mean
this is a challenge for all of us
whether it's mental health you know drug
drug and alcohol this is a challenging
time because you know well we we know we
all have family members and we know
people who are getting through the day
how they're getting through it however
that is right now and it's just a scary
time don't lean on one another as much
as we can without being around what
about it that's what I was gonna ask is
what what counsel would you give is
there a number there a place to reach
out did you like what did you do what
would you have done I guess is what I'm
saying
here you know I think I think that if
you're struggling you know a theater if
you're ever struggling with drugs or
alcohol you've got to find somebody
because here's the thing most you're
usually the last one to acknowledge it
your friends and everybody they kind of
know already or they probably do know
and you've a alienated them so if you
start isolating and because the people
that know you realize your behavior is
different so you isolate and then you've
kind of alienated those relationships
you go to places and do things that make
you feel good the first thing you have
to do is you've got to go talk to
someone you trust someone you love that
isn't gonna beat you up about coming to
them that they're gonna understand and
try to help you so that it's really hard
and it's really hard at knitting you
know that you have have an issue I tried
and tried and tried and tried and tried
and wit on my own I know I always say I
quit every day I just could not start
back up again today so yeah it's it's a
monster man Rex Chapman here on the Rich
Eisen show and again you are such a
force of positivity Rex it really is
amazing and I'm seriously like I see it
really sounds funny to hear you say that
because when my friends hear people say
that they it's so true and I also see
just the wide range of people who are
retweeting you from all different walks
of life like who's the one that you see
you you saw retweet you I know you you
you do give a lot of the emojis of the
flexing the muffled muscles and saying
hey but who's the one who's retweeted
you that you're like oh my god that's
something else well Arnold
Schwarzenegger Mark Hamill in mom apiece
just a Ben Stiller Chris Pratt uh
Soledad O'Brien a lot of the media
people and then then people from you
know celebrities and famous people
entertainers
politicians that I don't really know at
all from other countries that have kind
of you know they're all kind of people
that like to look at the same stuff and
need some positivity and laughs here and
there so that part of it is really cool
to me because I know there's so many
members of the media you know in every
big market little market that follow
that this silly account that you know it
just has it picks up a lot of traction
and that way you can spread a lot of
good stuff that you know well to so many
people because those people all have
pretty big accounts as well right and
then so what's the one that you're happy
about the most I mean walk me through
some of the ones that you did you like I
told my friends and so now today
last week I out of nowhere I looked I
said I had a I had a new follower and I
look saw who it was and said told my
friends all right it's over I can leave
now so all done Tommy Chong I'm followed
by Tommy Chong yeah we amen we had him
we had him in we had him in studio a few
months ago and it was just how was it oh
my god he's he he Chris isn't he 80 now
or something yeah he's up there and it
was amazing I mean yeah unbelievable
it's fantastic Tommy Chong Tommy Chong
so you could direct message Tommy Chong
now if you wanted to right yeah yeah
exactly I wouldn't but I'll say it you
could start like a bong or blunt right
instead of charge look we understand me
to second hand information information
you know and again it's funny you know
you're you're
love for dogs too has been amazing I
just love all those videos about dogs
and and yeah you know dogs bro I do what
do you what what dogs do you have do you
have a couple or one - yeah I have a I
have a German Shepherd I've had German
ship I just had one that I actually had
- I gave to a friend of mine my one of
my favorite dogs ever ate but I had to
get rid of him when I went to rehab and
I ended up being one of the greatest
dogs for my friend and family there in
LA and they just had a baby and then ace
had to be put down the mom we so sorry
you're a tough man tough for them tough
for us but I've got a German Shepherd
named goose after ace of course very
good and yeah and he's terrific he's all
kinds of weird not the smartest German
Shepherd I've ever had it's funny Chris
our dogs Dylan in Halo or our rescue
Golden's and white gold and Suzy took a
video of them of them like doing a tug
of war or something she took a video and
she said to me she says send it to Rex
for his feed now we submit videos you
know it's the best thing ever
like you you gave me one the other day
that you couldn't necessarily put out
and it was great right what was great
the guy singing the song about staying
home yes look like Letterman it showed
up on my feet I sent it to you and I'm
like I don't think I can post this one
this thing's a directly up your alley it
was that's great all right before I let
you go our question of the day cuz we're
just having some fun
sports world to go down a little bit of
a diversion wormhole is you know Apple
is created hours trying to create a way
for you to claw back a text that you
didn't mean to send somebody to kind of
hit unsend we're like what would you
want it
sports moment whether it's from your
professional career or your routing
career or whatever your when you're
growing up what well I thought you were
taking a shot at me for a second with
Apple no I had it's the technology we're
talking about technology the sport what
sports moment would you want to draw
back double your career he'd unsend on
one in a race yes a sports moment okay
and you know I really don't know I I can
remember being just one of the first
times I've ever been embarrassed on a
basketball court
I was this senior in high school playing
a big game against our archrival at home
and I did pulled the old Eric Bledsoe
referee hand me the ball and I drilled
the ball and bounced all the way to a
skort before anybody really realized
that fans were going crazy the referees
finally realized and I just lost it but
was mortified yeah so that's it again my
guess what my guess would have been
Laettner you know beaten Kentucky any
moment that oh I thought that I was a
part that's well there's one and then
what would be the any moment I guess oh
yeah of course
Laettner that was after I was in school
but that was just soul-crushing yeah
yeah that's not yeah yeah I don't know I
think that's probably it yeah and firm
so many many people around here you'd
hit unsend on behalf of millions of
people from your area
you're too much that is so funny you are
so damn funny man Rex keep doing what
you're doing keep doing what you're
doing well my wife and I will keep
sending
well we'll keep sending your dog videos
hoping that we crack your lineup you
know I know you're very tough you're
very discerning yeah shot selection is
great I don't sweet too much I know I'm
a volume tweeter just like iOS shooter
right and we're showing I love it and
we're showing right now for the next two
weeks a hundred percent of the profits
of blocker charge t-shirts tell us what
what this is all about yeah it's going
to code release on that I set up with
partnered with my opioid foundation Rex
Chapman Foundation and we partner with
bluegrass Community Foundation here in
Kentucky and actually in the last two or
three days we've given out about
twenty-five thousand dollars five
thousand to God's pantry here in
Kentucky ten thousand the Harrison
County Hospital its first patient coded
patient there two weeks ago I'm drawing
a blank on a couple other donations and
then we're also as the week unfolds
we're gonna be giving out more across
the country to places that I hotspots
that I kind of crossed paths with over
the over the years
Miami Charlotte Phoenix LA and then you
know of course New York and Seattle so
we're gonna try to hit as many places
and we can and if you keep donating will
keep doling it out hey y4k why.com
correct that's where you can get it
kentucky free kentucky done it they're
very good and then get those blocker
charged t-shirts going on I'll go online
later on we'll get a whole bunch for my
family we love it we love you wreck my
kids I showed my kids that video
yesterday of use of the of the truck on
the ice they freaked out and then they
freaked out oh my gosh that was great I
know I know I don't want to give much
away I want people to go to your Twitter
feed to see it if they haven't already
seen and then of course if you do look
at the video that I put on Rex's radar
screen of that guy telling everybody
about social distancing and only his
very special man yeah earmuffs your
mother take care of yourself you the man
you got at Rex Chapman